اربطوا أحزمة المقاعد الخاصة بكم وتوقفوا عن إرسال
هذه الرسالة العارية من طيار جنوب غربي
هدد بتغيير مسار طائرته
عندما بدأ راكب على متن الرحلة من هيوستن
إلى كابو سان لوكاس بإسقاط
صور عارية للمسافرين الآخرين ،
لذلك يستمر هذا أثناء سفرنا
سيتعين عليّ أن أتراجع
إلى البوابة ،
وسيضطر الجميع للنزول ،
سنضطر إلى المشاركة في الأمن
وستتلف هذه العطلة ،
لذا أيًا كان أي شيء من هذا الإنزال الجوي ، توقفوا
عن إرسال الصورة التالية ، دعنا نحصل على
أنفسكم  إلى التحرير والسرد لذلك أنا سعيد جدًا لأن
إيريكا هيل معي الآن لأننا
كنا نثير هذه القصة طوال الصباح
ولم أستطع معرفة
ما كان يحدث لحياتي ، كانوا
يسقطون صورًا عارية حول الطائرة.
ما زلت غير قادر على معرفة سبب قيام أي شخص
بذلك والاعتقاد بأنها فكرة جيدة
أو أن أي شخص يريد رؤيتها ،
لكن حدث أن الهواتف ليست شيئًا جميلًا ،
لذا كانت هذه رحلة الأسبوع الماضي
هيوستن إلى كابو سان لوكاس أ
رحلة الخطوط الجوية الجنوبية الغربية ، لذا فإن راكبة قامت بتصوير
هذا الفيديو تخبر CNN أنها ركبت
الطائرة مع صديقاتها
وفجأة حاول شخص ما أن ينزل على الهواء
صورة ترفض تلك الصورة لكن
شخصين أمامها
قبلا أنها كانت عارية.
الصورة لم تكن تريدها ، أتساءل لماذا قام
راكب آخر بتنبيه ذلك إلى
مضيفة طيران تقول ، هذا ما
يحدث ، هناك شخص ما على متن
الطائرة يسقط
هذه الصورة
يحاول إرسالها إلينا
تخبر المضيفة الطيار  الطيار
يجعله لا يجعلني أقلب هذه الطائرة
حول الإعلان ، فأنا أقول إنني أحب
الجزء إلى حيث هو مثل أي
شيء مثل هذا الإنزال الجوي مثل مهلا أبي ، لدينا
هذا الشيء الجديد على هواتفنا
، وبالتالي انتهى بهم الأمر بشكل صحيح
تعلم الجميع  كيف نتصرف ، توقفنا عن إرسال
الصور ، لم يكن عليهم أن يديروا
الطائرة حولهم وأقلعوا ، لكن من
الواضح أن هذا هو ما تعرفه مثل شيء
جديد آخر
لا أعرف شيئًا تقنيًا